السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اهلا بكم الى
موجز الاخبار من الجزيره قال الرئيس
الاوكراني ميرسي ان قوات بلاده تحافظ على
مواقعها في مدينه بخمول شرقيه البلاد
وتتقدم في مناطقه اخرى واضاف انه ناقشه مع
قاده قوته مساله توفير الاسلحه وتعزيز
الدفاعات الجويه
في المقابل اكدت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
القوات هي الروسيه تستهدفت مواقع للقياده
الاوكرانيه ومنشات الطاقه تعملوا على
تشغيل مصانع عسكريه توضح المتحدث باسم
الوزاره ان القصف حققه جميع اهدافه
دوليه للطاقه الذريه ان خط نقل الطاقه
الاحتياطيه الى محطه زفروجه النوويه تضرر
بسبب القصف واضافه من الثلاثه محطات نوويه
اخرى في اوكرانيا استعاده مستويات انتاج
الكهرباء بعد الهجمات الصاروخيه الاخيره
على وزاره الدفاع اليابانيه الى كوريا
الشماليه فقط ثلاثه صواريخ بالستيه متوسطه
المدى سقطت جميعها خارج المياه الاقليميه
لليابان وقدمت طوكي واحتجاجا لدى سفاره
كوريا الشماليه
وطالبتها بوقت فيما سميته خطواتها
لاستفزازيه من جهتها قالت الخارجيه
الامريكيه اين يتلقى في يوم جانجا
الصواريخ يؤكد تاثير برنامجها الصاروخيه
غير الشرعيه على زعزعه الاستقرار في
المنطقه
اعلنت هيئه المحاميه التونسيين تنظيم ما
وصفته بيوم غضب الوطني يوم الخميس المقبل
رفضا لقانون الماليه الجديد وبررت الهيئه
واحتجاجا بما وصفته بالتداعيات الخطيره
على الشعب واذ قال كاهله بالاعباء
الضريبيه المفرطه
من جهته قبل الاتحاد التونسي للشغل انه لن
يبقى مكتوف الايدي توجها الازمه
الاجتماعيه واضاف انه سيبدا تحركات
الاحتجاجيه سيحدد موعدها خلال اجتماعي
هيئته الاداريه الشهر المقبل واوضح اتحاد
الشغل التي يعتزم اطلاقها مع منظمات
المجتمع المدني لا تزالوا في مرحله
المواجهه
في المقابل قال الرئيس التونسيه وقيس سعيد
ان التحدي الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه يعد من
اهم التحديات التي يواجهها التونسيون
واعطف سعيده ان افتعال الازمات وفقدان بعض
المواد الاساسيه والمحاولات التي باتت
معلومه للجميع لا يمكن ان تستمر
اعتمدت الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
بالاغلبيه قرارا يطلب فتوى محكمه العدل
الدوليه بشان اسرائيل المستمر بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني في تقرير مصيره
ويطلبوا القرار راي المحكمه بشان الاثار
القانونيه في انتهاك اسرائيل واحتلالها
طويل الامد للاراضي الفلسطينيه
اشكركم على متابعه الموجزه لما كنتم
اوقاتكم بكل خير